and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a are tonight's review Hunger
Games Mockingjay part 2 Wow
oh wow whoo
oh that is the greatest hi I've ever
been on in my life whoo-hoo sorry I just
combined two of the great elements ever
crystal meth and ecstasy
I call it crystal meth fatigue and I
have been on the greatest I ever oh my
god the whole summer I was out man oh
did I miss anything oh really
some of the highest grossing movies of
all time huh well that sucks
I guess we should probably do a more
underground independent project let's
talk about Hunger Game five spiders oh
sorry I'm still coming up at that high
so there's this girl named Katniss and
she's upset because her boyfriend is
crazy man it's most celebrity couples
but that won't stop her from taking on
an unfair world that doesn't treat her
properly and she's using the power of
her celebrity to change our unfair ways
oh wait I'm sorry I'm confusing her for
Jennifer Lawrence can't dance is taking
on an unfair world and she's using the
power of her celebrity to change our
unfair ways seriously though I'm a bum
but we're on the same said I get paid
more than her hey we should feel lucky
she has her own action figure so they
tell Kenda said they had to rally all
the people together so they get all the
winners of the other Hunger Games
together like in every other movie and
they send them out to destroy the
capitana and Katniss is like they aren't
you the person that just got married yes
I am and we're gonna spend our honeymoon
in the capital after we take it over you
are so dead I know but it turns out that
city is littered with booby traps from
Raiders of the Lost Ark but it's okay
because her crazy boyfriend is there
wait what I'm a total liability and I'm
gonna kill you all if you get out of
line I'm gonna kill you I'm promising
you I'm gonna get out of line you should
kill me
don't tempt me I am tempting you kill me
I am emotionally compromised by this
which is why you should totally kill me
huh I just figured
you weren't here to sabotage me again
why the killing me thing is a good idea
well I won't be had in this way I'll be
had in a completely different way
I even good now and I'm gonna try and
kill you now do you believe me you watch
it mister I'm only gonna give you five
more chances I'm starting to wonder
who's more crazy here but the soldiers
convinced know that Katniss is dead
again and again and again and anyone
realized she dies about as well as the
Lord the Rings character so they go
underground in the sewer so they're not
seen but what horrifying creation comes
after them when the first film it was
giant dogs the second film giant baboon
what other computer-generated really not
scary thinking we throw at them giant
CGI ulis people who can mist if he's
just by putting her hand on one of their
faces this is working it's okay I'll
break his neck we can break their necks
really ha it's nowhere near as
frightening as a giant bunch of black
goo yeah what did the black goo do again
miss black goo I don't know black goo it
does black gooey stuff oh by the way the
guy that got married died well duh he
was dead the minute he said I do so snow
offers all the refugees a place to be
safe but it's okay because bombs come
and blow up whoa
no really whatever your political
leaning is just the time this is coming
out everything Wow I I need to go
into the uncomfortable corner
and so the giant battle the giant climax
the big moment that all these movies
have been building up to totally doesn't
happen yet turns on mod from The Big
Lebowski she was the bad guy if I can't
this actually kills her instead of snow
really really no you don't understand
story wise this makes a lot more sense
I know it's just is you have to choose
between her own revenge and what's best
for the world I mean yeah yeah it's just
it's proof that all the heroic
propaganda they be pushing in the movie
rarely has the ending you'd expect yeah
but all the advertising all the movies
I'm gonna kill snow I'm gonna kill snow
entity really he goes after the chick
nobody remembers in lost world do you
want reality or not obviously not I was
high most of the summer well it's okay
because we give the unbelievably
realistic ending that nothing happens to
her she goes home has a family nobody
ever comes after her and a crazy
boyfriend is just suddenly not crazy oh
you did the fanfiction last chapter of
Harry Potter out she has nightmares
that's not totally happy I think this is
a very clear example of not having your
cake but eating it too that's Hollywood
baby and and so ends your Willian young
adult book series that gave birth to
every other Orwellian young adult book
series seriously you can combine them
all together and have the divergent
hunger Maze Runner but at least it had
the future coolest character from the
force awakens for about five seconds
yeah why was she in there those twin
girls made more sense you know because
every book series for young people now
have to have twins for some reason or
maybe I was just seeing double that
wasn't awfully long hi this is just a
refund sing died yeah change oh come on
have a diarrhea good man change come on
I'm living the Hunger Games every day in
my life though I am learning how to do
my own photosynthesis
you